Welcome back to the David Pakman show. Okay.
Let's go back to the phones at (617) 830-4750.
We've got, yeah,
a lot of people holding today. Uh, let's see
where we want to go next. Why don't we talk
to a lot of area codes I don't recognize.
Let's go to our caller from the six 47 area
code. Who's calling today? Uh, from six 47.
Oh, Hi David. It's a Eric from Toronto.
Hey Eric. What's going on today?
Okay.
Yeah. I've wondered if, uh, if you know much
about, uh, citizen's assemblies. I've been
reading a lot about the topic lately and I
wonder what you thought about them as a problem
solving mechanism.
No, I've not heard of them by that name, but
what are they? Because I think it, it sounds
like it's something I know by a different
name.
Yeah.
Okay. I, citizen's Assembly is an assembly
of randomly selected citizens convened to
consider a problem, listen to experts and
deliberate with help from some moderators
and propose a solution. It's kind of like
legislation by Jerry.
Yeah, right, right, exactly. I was going to
make the analogy to the jury. I mean, listen,
I love the idea in principle and one of the
biggest problems we have, I don't know how
big of a problem it is in Canada, but in the
u s one of the biggest problems we have within
the sort of sphere of elected officials is
that they are coming disproportionately from
narrow slices of society in terms of their
professions, in terms of their financial circumstances,
and in other ways it's a relatively homogenous
group that lacks diversity in ways that I
think would be important. I'm not talking
about racial diversity, but in these other
ways, the problem is like I've been on a jury
and it's pretty bad, and I did a segment,
which now I think has more than half a million
views on youtube saying we have to recognize
that there's just a lot of people that are
ignorant, dumb, stupid, call it whatever you
want.
I don't want to stigmatize it, but there's
just a lot of people that lack information
and cognitive ability. So I want more diversity
of voices and deciding how our society should
be organized and, and weighing in on policy.
At the same time. I've been on a jury where
two thirds of the jury members didn't even
understand what the law was that we were supposed
to make a guilty or not guilty determination
of. So it also scares me and I understand
like when you go back, you know, to Plato
and see his anti a democracy views, I understand
them. I'm not, I'm not an anti, I'm not against
them ocracy but I understand the problem with
just letting random people be in charge of
stuff. I've been on juries, you know.
Well I think that's a very good point. Although,
you know, it has been tried in a couple of
areas of the world such as a British Columbia
had one about electoral reform. Ireland had
one about abortions. And I think really the
results speak for themselves there. If you
can get experts in front of these people,
if you can have moderators, uh, you know,
getting them to discuss in a productive way,
people really do change their minds and come
to Ike, what I think are reasonable solutions
to complicated problems.
Oh, that's fantastic. I mean it's, it's heartwarming
and inspirational is that there are examples
of it having worked well and I would be super
in favor of the idea as long as I felt good
about, you know, not listen, 60 million people
voted for Trump, but it's like how, how, how
critically are you thinking? If you go to
the ballot box and say, I want Donald Trump
to be president, then that's what's really
scary to me.
[inaudible] yeah. One of the things it seems
like citizen's assemblies can really change
if they took over a lot more of a legislative,
a role from elected representative is that
the role of political parties in society,
you could be marginalized a lot and that might
get rid of a lot of the toxic culture around
politics that is troubling many areas of the
world today.
Completely agree. Although I think that there's
also the possibility that in so doing it allows
for other new problems that we would have
to solve. But super interesting and I'll look
into it further. I appreciate you bringing
it up.
All right. Have a great day.
Okay. You too. Appreciate the call.